I thank you so our final talk for the
workshop is by um
separations
thank you thank you so much
um thank you uh organizers for such a
great workshop and sorry that I cannot
be there in person
I'm going to talk about Black Box
separations in a Quantum world the title
is a tiny bit different from what I was
posted but it's pretty close and I'm
going to focus on results that are from
a crypto paper from the last crypto with
co-authors pair climbing how
and myself
and yeah so let's get started
just to check you do do you see like the
Zoom things
on the screen I guess it's fine okay
nothing that you shouldn't see okay
perfect so
Let's uh go over some Basics I know
everyone there knows them uh in part I I
prepared them because I guess some
others might see the talk but I hope you
don't mind you go over some Basics and
you know we have assumptions in
cryptography of course and the reason
that we have them is that
P different from MP seems to be it is
necessary for most of the interesting
things in crypto we don't know how to
prove it therefore we have assumptions
ideally we want to assume just PDF from
MP even that we cannot do we make a
stronger assumptions than we are fine
with it and you know we have panels like
yesterday who discussed what assumptions
are better and here are some properties
that are
typically considered good having a
generic assumption that is for example
one-way function as opposed to factoring
that we can have a family of
implementations for it that's a
preferred thing if it's falsifiable if
it's real study and maybe inspired by
physics something that is simple to
estate is also good to have so we make
such assumptions and then we do
construct the Primitive that we want to
construct and then we give a proof of
security so that's how we do business in
cryptography
and there are two major tasks I mean
there are more than these two but those
two classical questions the cryptography
are secret key encryption and public
encryption
for secret encryption the situation is
pretty good when it comes to assumptions
in particular we know how to use one-way
function to do essentially everything we
want to do and that is in fact minimal
and till we actually prove them to exist
and that's a different story but so far
this is the minimal assumption but when
it comes to public cryptography the
situation is really not good for
authentication it's fine signatures we
can base them on one way functions we
pay an efficiency cost
that's kind of okay from an efficient
from an assumptions perspective but when
it comes to public key encryption the
situation is really bad it's more like
an art of picking the right structured
assumption like LW or ddh or something
else and there is a survey advertising
by my advisor so you can look at it to
see some of them it's it's a great
survey so what is the big question can
we based publicly cryptography in
particular public encryption and one
with functions
and that's open we still don't know how
to solve it and
uh it's been a while so what do we do
maybe we can cry or go go home but not
all of us did that so in popularity on
rudition 89 explained to a large extent
why we have failed they showed that at
least for a construction that is
so-called black box there is no way of
getting there from when we function to
public encryption and let me just say
quickly what the black box construction
is that basically the only definition of
black box construction that I will have
in the stock it is going to be a
construction that
uses a generic assumption and uses it as
a Oracle in the implementation so we use
the one we function we don't care how
it's implemented we use it as an oracle
I need the proof of security we also
treat everything as a black box whenever
we can like the implementation of the
one-way function again or the generic
assumption will be used as a black box
the adversary will be also used as a
black box and black box construction is
relative wise they have some nice
properties in addition to relative
lighting they have some properties that
are practically relevant they are
typically more efficient they compose
better
uh if we don't really look at the code
of the adversary you might plug in
something that is not really a circuit
there potentially if you don't reset it
you might plug in like a Quantum solver
or a human brain so there are there are
better for many ways therefore
um you know if you make an unconscious
not black box construction Black Box
typically it's considered interesting
but when we don't even know how to do
something uh there are of course even
more interesting so
um it's a very influential line of work
initiated by the importance on Ruby's
paper
now today's theme of The Talks Of course
were about Quantum and of course I'm
going to get into that so in a Quantum
World cryptography is changing uh you
see the number of papers going up and up
every conference
so it's now an elephant in the room that
more and more people actually do talk
about but how does it affect
cryptography technically it really
depends on which angle you look at it
there are uh kind of good sides and bad
sides in sense so adversary could be
Quantum so that's not the great news
because we have to update our protocols
and make them Quantum safe or post
Quantum but it's also the case that
honest parties could be Quantum so they
could Implement things in a Quantum way
that we couldn't do before so that
brings up new avenues that could be like
a smiley face now
and of course we are going to revisit
everything in light of having Quantum
power and Quantum communication how does
that affect reductions and separations
um typically how it works is that we
pick your favorite reduction or
separation I have the separation in red
because that's what I'm typically more
interested in or naturally attracted to
so you pick your favorite reduction or
separation then you need to extend the
definition of The Primitives that are
involved somehow to the quantum setting
so the pick that you had in the first
line maybe was from the classical
setting and then you need to think about
what it means to have something like
that in the quantum settings so The
Primitives involved should be extended
to the quantum setting and then we
revisit whether the reduction or the
separation holes
and this extension of the Primitive to
the quantum setting I would say it comes
in many flavors but I think you can
think about it in
several hierarchies that I think all are
very interesting in their own so the
most basic extension of the Primitive to
the quantum setting is that you just
keep everything classical in terms of
the implementation the input output and
you only give Quantum power to the
adversary so that's the post Quantum or
Quantum safe setting
but there this is kind of mechanical so
you don't really need to define
something from scratch usually the post
quantum definition is natural you can
make it kind of a mechanical process as
well but one step going further you can
take the primitive
that existed and now keep every
communication classical
input classical but give Quantum
computation to the processes that go
from those inputs to outputs and that's
going to be more relevant for the focus
of the talk for example we can have a
key agreement protocol in which the
messages are classical but the parties
other symbol are not classical anymore
and they're Quantum powered
um
and the third is that you know we go
really beyond
the uh limitation of even keeping the
messages classical and that goes to a
lot of topics that where the subject of
talks today
uh you can think about commitments or
many other Primitives in which now even
the communication is classical which
means that of course all the parts it
will be the communication even is
quantum which means that Even parties
will be Quantum powered as well so I
really want to emphasize that there is a
merit in every level of Going Quantum
here and revisiting the questions of
course going all the way to Quantum is
interesting but it's also good to keep
in mind that you know the internet is
not going to become Quantum tomorrow and
it's not clear how long it takes maybe
we will get local Quantum Computing
really faster than having really
full-fledged Quantum communication as
well so the questions in the middle are
also interesting
so what is known about the separation
side in the quantum world it's not a
survey but I'm listing some of the works
that I think are interesting or I'm
aware of so the work that really started
this line of work is the work by Jose
Yamada and yamakawa
from Asia Crypt 2020 the best paper of
that year in which they showed that if
you
revisit the relation between Collision
resistant hash functions and chapter
permutations
for which we know a classical Black Box
Separation by Simon and a generalization
to the chapter permutation by heitner at
all you can prove a similar Black Box
separation when you allow the
implementation of those Primitives to be
Quantum but you keep every kind of input
output classical still
so they defined what it means to have a
Quantum Black Box reduction and reprove
their separation and there are also
results that showing that when we have
Quantum messages things could be even
more surprising and maybe more
interesting technically in particular
pseudo-random States
do not imply only functions in a black
box way this is the crash mirrors result
but they do imply non-attractive
commitments in a black box way and from
the two papers appearing in crypto last
crypto so uh you know you don't have to
repeat so one way functions are not of
course necessary for Quantum
non-attractive commitments but there is
also a paper from just the last year
that presented a few days ago that
showing that if you actually emphasize
on having classical messages
in your non-attractive commitment there
is evidence that black box constructions
from Bombay functions
so it's incomparable to that you can
separate it officially from Bombay
functions and show that some previously
known separations when myself and
Rockwell extend to the setting as well
there are not many other papers around
so Black Box separations in a Quantum
world is kind of like a white West so
you can find many basic questions that
are still open and interesting to look
into and my favorite one that I'm going
to focus for the rest of the talk is
going to be about the question that I
started to talk with
namely what's the relation between key
agreement and one-way functions when we
move to the quantum wall
by the way I'm not really sure how how I
would hear the questions if you said
some I hear you well so if there was a
question here yeah it will just speak up
so everyone has a question so you'll
hear us thank you thank you so of course
it stopped me at any time if you had any
question so this is the main question of
the talk so what is known about it
what's the relation between them
of course if you allow
Quantum communication as well then the
answer is known so bb84 tells us that we
can have the statistically security
agreement if you have Quantum
communication
and if you are also really emphasizing
on public encryption and you know we are
okay to make when we function as an
assumption there is a recent uh
series of works that show you can
actually just assume a function and get
public encryption if your public key is
somehow a Quantum state with some
carefully stated properties of how many
copies you you need to have or whether
it can be tampered with or not but
essentially there are positive results
that state that you can have something
like that if you as I said allow Quantum
Communication in particular if your
public is quantum
but it doesn't answer the question that
I want to focus which is
the question of getting key agreement
using classical communication and
Quantum computation
is it possible to do it from one way
functions or symmetric cryptography we
still don't know
and the question was first formally
stated
at least in public Arena by this in the
same paper that initiated Black Box
separations in the quantum setting the
Asia paper
the initial versions of the paper I
think even mentioned this question even
though I think many people maybe have
heard about it before but this was
before the first time stated
officially and in this talk I'm going to
give some partial negative answers to
the question and hopefully you will
be motivated to at least take on some of
these or maybe go all the way and solve
the full-fledged version of the question
um and that's going to be the rest of
the talk
so what is the outline for the rest of
the talk I'm going to define the problem
formally a little bit more formally than
State what is our conditional partial
impossibility result
we will see some details of the attack
and also I will explain the
condition under which we prove the
results which is the conjecture why we
make it what is it and how is it
Justified and wrapping up with some
questions
so I'm going to focus on key agreement
from a random Oracle rather than a
one-way function or hash function which
is not surprising we use random molecule
for proving possibilities or
impossibilities so let's uh let's first
Define this formally and then we will
see why is it okay to work with this
model even if we want to really study
say some something like when we function
so if Alice and Bob have access to a
random Oracle
it means that you know they have access
to this function H which is a huge
gigantic Boolean function for Simplicity
let's say it's Boolean the capital N
here is something like 2 to the security
parameter
so think about
the iusd or the security parameter which
is a little bit non-standard in the
stock but I think because it has to do
with degree of something that's why I
chose it so this is like 2 2D so it's a
huge table random table and they have a
random access to this table they each
ask up to D queries to this Oracle I'm
talking about say classical setting now
so they each ask a d queries to this
Oracle and they of course can interact
back and forth and at the end they
output a key each of them the keys
should be the same and the security says
that an EVS dropper who looks at the
exchange messages and asks a polynomial
number of queries over d
cannot really guess the key better than
a random guess up to an negligible
advantage
so this is what key agreement in a
random Oracle model is defined what it
is
if you could do it why do we care about
it in the random worker model if we can
show how to do it in the random Oracle
model the practitioners don't really
care whether you make it one-way
function I guess they just plug in their
favorite hash function and they have a
great key agreement protocol that would
likely be secure even if you break all
these beautiful structured problems like
lwe or ddh so that would be really
fantastic but not P equal to MP of
course but if it's not possible and if
you can rule out the key agreement from
a random Oracle by breaking it with a
polynomial number of queries regardless
of the efficiency of the attack it is
still rules out the possibility of
basing your primitive on one way
functions or hash functions Collision
resistant High functions in a black box
way so it's a win-win study
and the both sides are interesting
of course the first one would be more
interesting but it might be not the case
so is it now possible to get really
keygament from random Oracles of course
the classical results in Epoch doesn't
really showed that you cannot do it and
further quantitative improvements show
that you can make the attack even
quadratic over the number of queries of
Allah if everything is classical and
because Miracle already had a protocol
that was
quadratically secure we know the
tightness we know that the result is
tight so it's kind of solved for the
classical case but
we are interested to know what happens
if Alison Bob can now have Quantum
computation
while they stick to their classical
communication and if we say they are
allowed to have Quantum con computation
we have to also allow them Quantum
access to this Oracle eventually that
Oracle will be a hash function and it
can be implemented in like a polynomial
size circuit and then whoever has
Quantum power can indeed run it in
Quantum superposition so even though
it's a random Oracle it will not be
polynomial size we still have to extend
our model and allow Quantum parties to
call it in Quantum superposition so how
do we do that well accessing Oracles in
Quantum superposition is something that
is defined and is well known even Beyond
random oracles but for the random
molecules case it was popularized by the
bone at all paper so it simply means
that we have this random Oracle which is
our hash function if it was a classical
query X we could ask it and the Oracle
would give us the answer
what is a Quantum version of this I'm
not going to Define it but roughly
speaking it means that you will have
registers for your query and your
answers and when you ask like basis
questions or that are exactly matching
these classical queries you will have
clearly defined answers and the quantum
algorithm can ask a linear super linear
combination of those queries with
complex coefficients and we'll get a
linear combination of balancers with the
same coefficients and they can of course
do measurements and do all that but the
queries are going to be Quantum so they
can be superposition queries to the
random market so that's what LS and Bob
can do
and what is known in this setting so the
setting is that everybody can access the
Oracle in Quantum superposition the
random Oracle and we stick to classical
communication what is known before there
are in fact some interesting results no
some observations and some technically
challenging results that are more like
fine-grained Flavor so first of all
let's remember that the miracle puzzle
protocol completely breaks down because
the classical Eve in that protocol has
to find one point among these squared
points that's how we get the escort
security but the using Grover search you
can exactly solve it in a linear number
of queries already so order of decode it
will be enough
but is that the end of the story No in
fact there are ways to make this super
linear secure and get back some
non-trivial security first it was
observed by Beyond
uh
yeah
Gordon and ishai yes uh and the
concurrent work also showed that you can
do it and that concurrent work
eventually turned into a crypto paper
that showed you can pretty much get to
quadratic security if you give others
and Bob Quantum access to the random
Oracle and it still needs quadratic over
D number of queries even if it can ask
the Oracle superposition
these are interesting uh starting points
in some sense going back to where we
were in the classical setting but it was
left open whether any poly query attack
can always be obtained
when we have a arbitrary protocol and
that's exactly the question we have
so what do we prove
so our main result is the following the
main result is that assuming a what I
would call a believable conjecture the
objective part is that is conjecture
about low degree polynomials that I will
talk about one can break any D query
Quantum kilogram protocol with classical
I'm going to repeat that it's a
classical communication all the time
it's going to be classical communication
but I emphasize that the protocol needs
to have perfect completeness
then you can break it with polynomial
number of queries
so I'm going to say a few words about
everything that I am emphasizing on this
theorem but before that let me say that
there are also other results that we
prove and I'm not going to focus on we
show that if only one of the parties is
classical you don't need the conjecture
so you can prove it unconditionally
unfortunately you still need to assume
perfect completeness
and finally
we kind of justify this conjecture by
showing that some form of conjecture
seems to be necessary
for such a impossibility result if you
want to break your
protocol classically in fact we break
the key agreement only with classical
queries so the attack that we give
doesn't really use the fact it doesn't
really leverage Quantum power it only
asks classical queries and as long as
you are limiting yourself to such
attacks you are going to be stuck in
um some unproved unproven conjectures
namely there are unproven conjectures
that depend on how which way they are
going to be resolved you might end up
having a positive result that is secure
against
classical queries attacks
so I'm going to talk about them also a
little bit towards the end
but uh let me go now over some
grievances so this is the theorem and
what is annoying about this theorem
and there are a few things that I can
point out so the annoying Point first is
that it's assuming perfectly complete
protocol why is it not a great thing we
even don't know how to achieve super
Linear Security
for the key agreement in the classical
setting from a random Oracle so if you
emphasize on perfectly secure protocols
makers protocol actually doesn't work
very random Oracle and it seems like you
can make it perfectly complete by like
hashing things and so on but it doesn't
really work and
if I may I even conjecture that it's not
going to work I don't know how to prove
it though it's I think boss said it's a
sour question once I he might not even
remember but I looked into this question
years ago and it's one of those
questions that if you prove it it might
not be really interesting for anyone but
you might be stuck with it for years so
I think it's impossible but I don't know
how to prove it so that's an annoying
thing another thing is that if you
assume perfectly complete protocols if
you uh so perfect completeness there is
in fact a much simpler proof of
impossibility by brockerski at all you
don't need really the full-fledged in
popular as a rudish machinery for that
but you know in the quantum setting we
still are stuck at this perfect
completeness the attack itself is
classical you might say it's a plus but
eventually it's an issue because we know
that the classical attacks uh are going
to be stuck somewhere because of the
barriers that I mentioned
and finally there isn't really no reason
so far that I'm aware of that mixed a
justification that the conjecture that
we make is really hard because the
conjecture that we make might as will be
easy and the perfect completeness case
might be easy that's actually what I
feel I think the conjecture is solvable
as opposed to some similar but different
conjectures have the same flavor
okay so let me go into a little bit of
technicalities before end of the talk so
some details of the attack and some
parts of it that might be useful even if
you don't really like the theorem or
results of this type so let me first
recall how the key agreement in the
classical setting can be broken in the
random worker model with the style of
the proof of the paper with pause
it's based on something we call Epsilon
heavy queries that is very simple to
Define so what is the attack
the attack says Eve asks every query
that is quote unquote Epsilon heavy from
the Oracle what is an Epsilon heavy
query Epsilon heavy means that alos or
Bob have a chance of at least Epsilon
asking it from the Oracle condition on
everything that you've known so far so
originally Eve only knows the transcript
but after it gradually gathers the
information about the Oracle it's the
probability distribution of Alice and
Bob's views in eyes of Eve can evolve
and at every moment if something has
excellent chance of being asked by Allah
um it's a heavy query that Eve can go
ahead and ask
and when there is no such heavy query
left to be asked if just simply outputs
the more likely key so that's the attack
that would work this is not exactly how
the attack of the paper is written but
if once you once you prove the more
complicated attacks of the paper
to work then you can also derive that
this simpler attack actually works
so the analysis says that you know
because everything that you ask had
Epsilon chance you can improve by
linearity linearity of expectation that
they're not going to be too many of them
the interesting thing really is to show
that this is enough information to find
a key and that's one that's much harder
but now that we have this attack at
least can we Define a Quantum version of
it so can we extend this Epsilon heavy
query attacker to the quantum setting
that should be doable so let's see what
we can do it's not as clear as it might
feel that it should be and the reason is
that
in the quantum setting the queries are
not really intuitive like the classical
settings so the queries don't really
coexist and it's not clear how to define
a Quantum Epsilon heavy in a really
Quantum way and even if you ask a
Quantum question from the oracle
you will have a challenge of whether you
should really read the answer or not
read the answer because if you read the
answer if you make measurements you
might get trouble down the road so there
was a lot of things that would make life
easier when we had a classical Oracle
because we just write down the
probability distribution see what query
is more likely to be asked can we ask it
and I want to say that in fact there is
a way to generalize it so I'm going to
now show you how to generalize the
Epsilon heavy query definition to the
quantum setting at least we will have an
attack candidate attack
how can we Define an Epsilon heavy query
then unless and Bob's queries are
quantum so the intuition is the
following classically if a query is not
asked
its answer remains uniformly random so
think about the distribution of the
answer of the query once you ask that
query the distribution is no longer
uniform you know the answer but before
you ask it is uniformly random and
before even Alice and Bob asked a query
from the Oracle it is going to be
uniformly random
but if Allah can ask Quantum queries of
course even a single query can touch
everything even a single query can have
non-zero coefficients for every
classical query so that's going to be
kind of making issues if you really want
to ask queries that are really ask from
the Oracle or not ask from the Oracle
because everything can be asked to some
extent so everything can be kind of
asked in a fuzzy way and that makes
things a little bit uh challenging so
what do we do we use ideas from the
compressed Oracle Machinery of genre and
we don't really use the full-fledged
version but some of the ideas are really
useful and we can use them to extend the
Epsilon heavy notion to the quantum
setting so what is the message one
message from that line of work uh it
says you can choose to purify your
Oracle and then you can choose your view
of the Oracle to be interpreted in a
different basis than the computational
Basis you can look at the answers in the
other bases in particular you can look
at them in the Fourier basis and here
the Fourier basis will be just the
Fourier over Z2 because the Oracle is
binary for each query the answers
distribution you can write it in Fourier
basis
and if a query is not asked it's still
uniform it means that in the Fourier
basis it's zero of the Fourier basis the
answer distribution of that point
and you can use that to Define what it
means to be Epsilon heavy by defining it
informally as follows it means that if
you measure
the answer
to that query
it's a classical query so if you measure
the answer to that query in the Fourier
basis
what's the chance of getting 0 versus
non-zero if the chance of getting
non-zero is more than Epsilon then it
means that the answer uh and I'm not
being formal about what what uh what is
even the quantum State here this is
going to be a Quantum state of everybody
involved Atlas Bob and the Oracle but if
you really just focus on the Oracle and
purify it and have a Quantum state that
captures the situation of the Oracle at
a particular moment and the Epsilon
heaviness according to this definition
says that
you have at least absolute chance of
getting non-zero answer if you measure
that answer in the Fourier basis so
originally everything is zero is zero
but once you make queries to the Oracle
the the Oracle state will evolve and
therefore some of the points might start
to have a answer distribution that gets
away from the uniform and this is kind
of a necessary condition to be read so
if if sorry a sufficient condition to be
read so if an answer to a point is away
from zero in the Fourier basis it means
that in fact it is touched so one of the
parties had really asked that query and
that's why the answer has been kind of
uh away from zero so this is the
informal definition you can also see the
formal definition the paper I'm going to
kind of show it to you but not really
get into the details the way you should
really think about it is that if you
have a Quantum estate that captures the
Oracle in the in the purified way every
point that is heavy is defined by saying
like I asked that point from the Oracle
and this is a classical point this is a
classical query if the answer is
non-zero in the Fourier basis with more
than Epsilon chance it is going to be
called Epsilon heavy so one comment that
this definition is kind of kosher in the
sense that it does in fact generalize
the Epsilon heavy definition from
it has some useful properties even if
your original algorithm was classical
you can show that there are
there are some relations between them I
don't emphasize on it this is not
equivalent but it does work also in the
if your original algorithm was classical
now Quantum Epsilon heavy attack you can
really write an attack immediately uh
based on the definition of quantum
Epsilon heavy queries and ask is this is
this attack gonna work or not so this is
the same exact as the classical attack I
just changed it to say that the eve
attacker
is now asking Quantum Epsilon heavy
queries from the Oracle whenever they
exist as long as they exist it keeps
asking them and when there are no more
Epsilon heavy queries left in the
quantum labor you just output the more
likely key
so efficiency of the attack is the same
as before you can show that linear
linearity of expectation guarantees that
you will not really ask too many queries
from the Oracle the interesting thing
again is to show that this is enough
information for Eve to really guess the
key
is this really all even needs and if you
really emphasize on your attack to be
classical intuitively this is actually
the best you can do because if something
is Epsilon heavy it means that you will
go ahead and ask it and if it's not
being asked by Allah you already know
what the answer will be it's going to be
uniform in the classical case so it is
um really natural to conjecture that for
classical attacks this is the best you
can do yes
um how does Eve know what are the
Epsilon heavy query I mean I'm not sure
that I understand the setting is that
like
um Eve is like analyzing Ellis and Bob
and make squares the real Oracle um yes
so so let me give you a little bit more
details I simplify things maybe too much
so so support your if and in your view
you will purify everything so you assume
that Oracle is purified and then you
look at the transcript condition on
knowing the transcript you will imagine
what would be the state of Allah or
Alice registers Pub registers and Oracle
registers
and now you can judge for with respect
to that specific Quantum estate you can
judge each and every Quanto each and
every classical queries to the Oracle to
be Epsilon heavy or not
Epsilon heavy means that if you read
that uh query in Fourier basis and
measure the answer it will be non-zero
with probability at least I can even
analyze it completely doesn't even need
to be anything Quantum here right I
could just sort of write it on paper if
I have like explaining indeed indeed
indeed yeah it's information theoretic
so you can you don't need any Quantum
because I'm not putting any bound on
Eve's computing power sure so you can do
everything in your head and then what
you have access to okay sure yeah the
axis is classical too yes
so it's really important that this is a
classical attack that's why it might be
limited too much
and
so the attack you can think about it to
be essentially the same attack but just
modifying this heaviness to be Quantum
heaviness
and how do we analyze it intuitively how
how this conjecture shows up
that I told you about if you want to
analyze this attack
at a very high level this is what's
happening
you keep asking the heavy queries from
the Oracle and at some point there is no
heavy Equity left
but you haven't found the key so suppose
the attack fails because if the attack
succeeds we are happy but if the attack
fails we want to get a contradiction
somehow so if the attack fails it means
that in eyes of Eve the keys are still
50 50.
so you can think about the quantum state
of Alabama and Oracle and you see that
if I measure the corresponding register
of Alice that I'll put the key it's 50
50. so I can't really kind of informally
speaking I can condition on that bit
being zero or condition on that being
one more formally I have to trace out
chase the state to get two different
states that correspond to the world that
that key is zero or that key is one
so in eyes of Eve I will have two
Quantum Estates
that have the following properties both
of these Quantum States will still have
no heavy query left originally there was
no Epsilon heavy queries but because the
keys were 50 50 I'm essentially lucky
formerly speaking on conditioning on an
event of two which means q0 or sorry
half event of size half it blows up
every probability at most by Factor two
so everything that was at most Epsilon
heavy is now two at most two Epsilon
heavy so still there is no heavy Equity
left this can be shown to translate into
having small influence of the variables
in a polynomial that you can write to
represent the state of the Quantum of
the Oracle more formally it's not going
to be one polynomial it's going to be a
distribution over polynomials after you
kind of measure LS and Bob's registers
but I'm not going to say how exactly
this translates to a polynomial but
there is going to be another condition
that this Quantum estate does because
Allah are asking at most equities and
this also translates to something that
can be formalized into a degree of a
polynomial that captures the state of
the oracle
uh the conjecture that we have states
that if you have two such Quantum
Estates that can be
Rewritten as polynomials as long as they
have low influence and low degree they
can be combined into one Oracle that is
both compatible with ls outputting zero
and LS and Bob outputting one so you
have two Quantum States you can combine
them to have the same Oracle but in one
of them
Alice is outputting zero and in that
Quantum estate LSR putting zero Bob is
outputting one so that would violate the
perfect completeness condition so what
is this uh polynomial compatibility
conjecture I'm going to tell you
formally it's very simple to State and
but just the the informal part of the
analysis is that the conjecture is
exactly trying to capture what the
contradiction you want to get and it
exactly says that if you have two
Quantum mistakes that have low in low
degree and low influence they can be
combined into a Quantum mistake that
violates perfect completeness
but what is the polynomial compatibility
can the conjecture I can Define it into
I can Define it in like I can give you
the definitions in one slide and the
conjunction in the next slide so
I'm going to define a very basic things
so suppose I have a polynomial here that
is over plus one over variables who
eventually get plus one or minus one so
without loss of generality it's a
multilinear polynomial
and the number of variables is huge is
the number of points queries you can
classically ask with Oracle think about
the polynomial of this form the degree
will be the degree of this polynomial is
just the maximum monomials number of
variables
what is the L2 Norm of this the norm of
the variable is like give it a random
input and take the Square value of it
that's what L2 Norm is we want to
normalize it if it's supposed to reflect
for example a Quantum estate and the
influence of each of these variables can
can defined in many equivalent ways
additional influencer variable that's
going to be exactly equivalent to this
but if you haven't it just means look at
all the monomials that have that
variable and sum their coefficients so
it means like how much kind of the
monomials that have that variable have a
weight
so we have influence degree and
supposedly normalize such a polynomial
all the time so what is the polynomial
compatibility conjecture it simply says
suppose you have two polynomials
multilinear polynomials over these large
number of uh variables exponentially
large number of variables and suppose
their degree is bounded so their degree
is bounded by D
and
uh I don't have a lot of time so I need
to plan but I think three minutes should
be enough so suppose the degrees are
bounded by D and suppose
they both have the same unit norm and
more importantly their influence is
bounded so the degrees are bounded the
influences are bounded how small are the
influence of each variable think about
the influences being sufficiently small
in terms of a polynomial over D but even
1 over 10 D is still I believe at least
I personally believe it to be work but
if you prove it with 1 over D Squared or
1 over D to the 10 or 1 over D to the
100 that's going to be enough
the conjecture says that if you have two
polynomials of low degree and low
influence their multiplication is
non-zero that's it so there is going to
be an input that they're both now zero
yes yes
they have very low influence and they
will touch a very few variables yeah the
output is supposed to be bullied
I'm pretty sure we have looked at them
but I uh can't discuss with you later
what are the differences we have there
are some ethereums that are closer than
what a theorems like the invariance
principle type theorems that are even
closer and they can give you proofs of
this for exponentially a small influence
and we proved this conjecture for some
range of parameters so in particular we
can prove it so one evidence that is
true is that we can prove it for the
case that the influences are
exponentially small as I told you
originally we kind of proves were
complicated but you can show a proof
based on basically careful applications
of koshish awards but exponentially
small influences would make the
conjecture correct but we want it really
for polynomialism so if you are okay
with exponentially many queries in
Breaking Q agreements probably you will
not be but this is going to be
unconditional for perfectly complete
protocols even that doesn't seem trivial
so if you want to break a Quantum
protocol with exponentially many
classical queries this is like 2 to the
D and D could be like 10 and 22 degree
is not really huge it's independent of
the number of queries of the Oracle so
that is still in my view now tivial but
it's more like the support for the
conject so what else do we know to be
about the conjecture as I said it seems
to be potentially true even for
influencers like 1 over 10 D maybe maybe
that's too ambitious but that seems to
be compatible and my favorite reason for
it is that our Fourier expert actually
believes that eventually he didn't seem
to believe it at first but quality
repair and now things is correct
and
I want to wrap up the talk so let me
just tell you that as I said the
conjecture that we have somehow is
necessary if you want to emphasize on
classical nature of the attack so there
is this conjecture by Ariana
is that if the conjecture is false you
can actually get a positive result that
is secure against classical query
attacks
so I'm not going to define the
simulation conjecture but roughly
speaking says that in the random Oracle
model if you have a Quantum algorithm
that makes the queries and outputs a bit
for most of the Oracle you can
approximate that probability arbitrarily
closely by asking only classical queries
to the oracle
so if you emphasize on
the algorithm Quantum algorithm really
being a total function this is not a
conjecture anymore it's a well-known
theorem that the query complexity of
quantum and classical polynomial related
but this simulation conjecture is that
you know I don't have a total function I
arbitrarily output 0 1 by quitting the
quantum Oracle quantumly and the
conjecture says you can still
approximate that probability for most of
the oracles classically
with polynomial number of queries it's
open it's a Well looked at conjecture if
it's false you can get a positive result
so what does it mean it means that we
have to probably look at Quantum queries
to really attack similar to impogation
so let me wrap up basically
um with the questions
I hope you will be interested into
looking at this polynomial compatibility
conjecture
based on the criteria of the panel
yesterday I think it's an interesting
thing it has both like a mathematical
Simplicity and implications that
motivate you
can you most important question probably
can you define a Quantum attack that
really goes outside this framework and
then therefore breaks things
unconditionally that seems to be the
most interesting thing uh maybe hardpod
is very interesting can you relate the
conjecture that I told you through the a
conjecture and there are similarities
that can be further investigated finally
is this kind of this sour conjecture can
is there a linear time attack for
classical protocols we perfectly
complete it's a very independent it's
independent of everything but I wanted
to eventually put it somewhere so these
are all about Quantum the last one is
not and that is all I wanted to talk
about thank you very much and if there
is a question let me know
any other questions
okay thank you so much thank you
thank you